what's up chess fans International
master levy Rosman here bringing you
another game of the day recap from the
feed HS calm online nation's Cup this
one is going to be different than usual
to match up between Viswanathan Anand
and Jana pom Moochie representing teams
india and russia respectively
but it's actually a very short game and
so actually after the game we're going
to add vicious thoughts which were
recorded during the livestream on this
game and this variation in his
preparation in particular so make sure
to stick around for that we usually
don't get video interviews of players
about the games so this one's a real
treat alright so Vichy starts out with
d4 Knight f6 c4g 693 Vichy I mean they
play everything at the highest of levels
but V she's an e4 guy so it's very
interesting to see him play directly
into Jana Palma she's preparation
anytime you get an opponent that never
plays an opening playing that opening
against you it's probably because they
have some prep so a Grune field and now
instead of employing the main line this
she goes for Bishop d2 the idea of
Bishop d2 is to play e4 but then take
the knight back here with the bishop so
Bishop g7 493 Bishop c3 and a very
common Grune field idea c5 this is not a
free pawn because this pawn structure
it's just it's it's not good for the
long term you're up upon just for a
moment but blacks always got queen a5
and different ways of targeting these
pawns and so for that reason but she
keeps the center intact with the move d5
takes takes and now as far as my data
base saw here there's a few games with
Queen a5 Queen D SIG's the move played
in this game has been played before it
has been played by leading green field
practitioner maxime beaugeois graph
if I'm not mistaken Napo actually had
this position or a bit of a
transposition to a similar position
against getting Tomashevsky so a very
strong Russian Grand Master so here this
she plays Queen d2 idea f4 Queen
supports this pawn and maybe wants to go
a 5 so castles f4 and by the way can we
just quickly pause here for a moment and
say that in what other opening on move
11 have the players developed nothing
off their back rank except for the
Queen's and the pawns
it's move 11 only the Queen's and the
pawns are
I mean everything else is on the last
rank so rune field is such a strange
opening but computer analysis shows it's
okay so rather than sitting around here
we get east six from yon trying to fight
back in the center and here as far as my
database saw all the moves are Bishop c4
reinforcing this pawn but here using a
little bit of a move order trick because
sometimes Knight f3 gets played although
if you play Knight f3 you don't actually
get a four so I guess it's completely
unique theory Knight f3 eats eggs e5 and
now Bishop c4 utilizing the pin very
unique idea I mean this is such a
strange move you almost never get this
and and white just wants to take back
with the Bishop reinforce the bishop
with the C pawn and have a dominant
control of the center so Yan plays
Bishop e6 and Vichy doesn't even take he
just castles okay so a little bit of
advice here if you're ever playing an
opponent and you are very clearly in
their preparation very clearly like they
have not spent any time in the opening
and it's a very strange position do not
go it is generally not a good idea to go
for the most forcing variation because
they will have prepared that already
it's sometimes even better to play a bit
more safely the computer might not like
that but it at least makes them think on
their own
whereas here yan tries to solve his
problems tactically by playing the move
d4 according to the engine he should
have gone rook da but then even if Frug
the eight you know Vichy reinforces
again this pin with rook ad one and
there is still very significant pressure
so Yong goes D for trying to you know do
something here with the bishops one of
the bishops will have to take the other
or maybe this she has to back up or if
it defend his Bishop somehow yeah not at
all actually here there's an idea that
it takes the computer about 10 seconds
to realize is so powerful so here the
move f5 stunning move completely
disregarding the threat on the bishop so
neppo takes and now look at this
'if I've in yesterday's video if you
haven't seen it go check it out for
Ruolin yay Dominguez we talked about the
initiative so it's creating threats on
your opponent not in the short term but
that will have a long-term positive
effect in your position so these two
threats notice that they will cut like
they will culminate in the final move
f 6 and there is no way for black to
stop queen h6 and 95 is there's no way
you know how I know there's no way young
nippon-ichi resigned in this position in
fact the position after Bishop takes e4
e5 is already so much losing now like I
said when you first plug this in it says
the black is is winning it sends like
minus 3 for black and then the computer
thinks forbidden goes whoa oh my
goodness this is winning for white and
yon upon me she resigns after f6 because
Queen h6 was coming with the threat of 9
g5 he had other moves besides Queen d7
but black is already in a world of
trouble because this pawn wedge along
with Queen h6 and a g5 is coming
like I said gonna be a brief video just
5 minutes
but stick around for the next few
seconds because we're about to get Vishy
Anand thoughts on the game we're now
joined by world champion Vishwanath on
and on who vichy what can you say about
the game that you just played versus
yonder palm Nishi
there isn't really much to say I mean
having having done commentary on the
candidates and also watching some
subsequent games just I mean I knew
Bishop e6 loses basically and I mean we
should not be should be 6 but d4 and I
just kept thinking well maybe he won't
sit down and think and maybe him just
blitz and he just blitzed out d4 and
then f5 is told that ancients don't
catch on to this immediately at least
the older slower ones but maybe that
gives humans a little hope but well you
answered the question that I was about
to ask I was gonna say do you think he
just mixed up his lines or he only took
a cursory glance at the position with
maybe not the best engine and so thought
that move id4 was good I mean no their
opposition's were Bishop e6 and d4 works
in specifically speaking you can start
with before and after castles
you cannot play Bishop e6 obviously
pretty complain I think 96 or something
but I mean here it's just on the spot f5
and E 5 and that's it right a nice line
the longest line is queen b 5 f6 Queenie
4 and I only have to pause for ok e 1 so
which means nothing else no in line
during in this line Danny yeah it's a
real Queen d7 if you don't Queen D 5 for
instance
ah so in the main line ft 4 instead of
Bishop e6 castles Bishop of five yeah 5
and 5 again yeah and now Bishop c4
e 5 now just follow that I just want to
explain one a little smaller than Queen
d5 okay f6 we need four and all I have
to watch this okay one and it's not
everybody if Queen h6 the point is Queen
e3 gets the Queen's off but rook 81 and
White is still just winning
and obviously the other thing is Queen
anywhere f6 I mean so Queen d8 Queen b6
Queen is it doesn't matter
I go f6 right no matter where the Queen
goes f6 and Queen h6 is still then he
goes 97 I go Queen at 6-9 takes f6
Knight g5 and then one more later or two
moves later to make anything Wow
and how long ago did you first notice
this line so how long have you been
saving this but the hope that you would
get to play it over the board
ah well my second term sent me a brief
set of ideas here or one of this this
was one of the easier ones and but boy
to check my form a second from all of my
matches mentioned to him that this was
even there and our notes from 10 years
ago Wow
how often does that happen I think for
people who don't know the you know the
way that prep at the highest level works
sometimes but how often do you prepare
something for particular matches and
then you never get to use it but then a
game many years later you end up winning
winning something based on what was
already done many years ago oh that
happens quite often but it's just that
this is a slightly extreme example
because writes one of the most trivial
lines but it happens quite often and in
fact ma'am I can boast about it again my
famous Wayne with Aronian was in fact
leftover preparation from the girlfriend
match right well the sort of thing
happens frequently well your game with
Aronian made our top 16 games in history
we have a running social media contest
right now where we paired them in a
knockout bracket and people vote so your
your game I think made it to the to the
next round or is still alive but maybe
maybe we made that contest too soon
because this game perhaps should have
been listed in it so